Space hotels with pools, gyms, bars, and gourmet
food have been one of the most common fantasies
shown in sci fi space movies. Given that only
553 people have ever reached low earth orbit
and only 24 people have gone past low earth
orbit, it seems like space hotels won't be
a thing for decades if not centuries. So,
you might be surprised to hear that people
may be staying in space hotels by the end
of this year. If you think about it, we technically
already have a space hotel which is the ISS.
Dozens of astronauts visit and stay on the
ISS for extended periods of every single year.
According to google though, a hotel is an
establishment providing accommodations, meals,
and other services for travelers and tourists.
Since ISS astronauts are employees and crew
members as opposed to travelers or tourists,
we can’t technically say that the ISS is
a space hotel right now. It should be noted
that though 7 private citizens have traveled
to the ISS throughout history meaning that
the ISS has been a space hotel in the past.
Surprisingly, Nasa actually wants to make
this a regular occurrence as they announced
that they were opening up the ISS for private
visitors in June of 2019. Nasa has been conducting
experiments and research on the ISS for two
decades at this point. They claim that there’s
still plenty of research to be done in low
earth orbit, but at the same time, they’re
looking to move onto bigger things like returning
to the moon and building a lunar base. So,
opening up the ISS for commercial tourism
is unfortunately the early stages of NASA
phasing out the ISS. Nonetheless, it does
make for an extremely cool tourist destination
in the meantime. Nasa revealed that they would
be allowing up to 4 private astronauts inside
the station at a time, and they would be charging
just $35,000 per day per visiting spacecraft.
This means that you can send as many people
as you can fit into a single rocket for the
same daily price of $35,000. If you were to
send a starship filled with 100 passengers,
each passenger would only be paying $350 per
day. Given that only 4 private astronauts
are allowed inside the station itself at any
given time though, it would be best to travel
with a group of less than 10 people. Each
visiting group will be allowed to stay at
the ISS for up to 30 days and Nasa will accept
two groups of visitors every single year.
Nasa was originally aiming to have private
astronauts on board by the end of 2020, but
clearly that didn’t happen. The problem
is that though the price to rent out the ISS
is actually extremely cheap, it's extremely
difficult to source a rocket and fund a rocket
launch. A startup called Axiom space is working
on accomplishing this though. In March of
2020, Axiom was actually able to book a crew
dragon launch with SpaceX that was supposed
to happen at the end of 2021. Since then,
it has been pushed back to the start of 2022,
but there’s no signs of the trip being cancelled
or anything like that. The plan is to send
three tourists on a 10 day trip to the ISS.
2 days will be spent in transit, but the tourists
will have a full 8 days onboard the ISS. Though
the price to rent out the ISS for 8 days only
comes out to a total of $280,000, when you
throw in the cost of the rocket launch, training,
and everything else involved in sending tourists
to space, we get a final price tag of $55
million per seat. Three wealthy individuals
have already booked the seats though. This
includes Larry Connor, Mark Pathy, and Eytan
Stibbe. Ironically, despite spending $165
million collectively, these men may not actually
be the first to rent out the ISS. You may
have heard that Tom Cruise was going to star
in the first movie that’s actually shot
in space. In September of 2020, it was announced
that Tom Cruise and Director Doug Liman would
be traveling to the ISS in October of 2021
to start filming. We haven’t received any
updates since then though, and it’s very
possible that this mission will be pushed
back into 2022. When I said that the Axiom
group wouldn’t be the first to rent out
the ISS though, I wasn’t talking about Tom
Cruise, I was actually talking about Russia.
You see, when Russia heard about the Tom Cruise
space movie, they decided that they had to
shoot a movie in space as well. Russia plans
to send their own actress to space in October
of 2021 to film a movie as well. And I have
a feeling that Russia is more dedicated in
actually achieving that timeframe, but we’ll
just have to wait and see. Anyway, getting
back to the axiom trip, though the tourists
are free to just relax and enjoy their trip,
they revealed that they’re looking to conduct
a plethora of experience and educational activities.
So, I guess it won’t be just leisure after
all. Aside from sending tourists to the ISS
with the help of SpaceX, Axiom is looking
to send tourists to their own space station.
At the start of 2020, Axiom received a contract
from NASA worth up to $140 million to build
a commercial module for the ISS. The module
is officially supposed to be used for research
and other applications. The module is meant
for commercial use though, so maybe it’s
meant for private research teams as well as
tourists interested in conducting their own
research. Aside from this research module,
Axiom is also looking to add habitation and
tourist modules onto the ISS as well. Adding
dedicated habitation and tourist modules would
complete the first steps in actually transitioning
the ISS into a space hotel as opposed to simply
being a research facility that regular people
can visit. The first of these modules is expected
to be launched in the second half of 2024,
and Axiom hopes to continue adding modules
throughout the second half of the decade.
Eventually, as Axiom's additions to the ISS
start to become too big or Nasa decides to
deorbit the ISS, Axiom is looking to disconnect
their modules from the ISS and form their
own commercial space station. This would be
the first space station dedicated to hosting
private tourists and researchers. Axiom is
not the only company looking to capitalize
on space tourism though, another company with
even grander visions is voyager. Unlike the
ISS and Axiom’s space station which have
components of research and education, Voyager
is looking to build a space station completely
dedicated to hospitality and tourism. And
their design is literally straight out of
a sci-fi movie. First of all, Voyager is attempting
to simulate gravity which no other space station
has attempted to do. Just like the movies,
Voyager plans to make a spinning station that
will basically pin tourists to the walls of
the station. The rotation is expected to simulate
⅙ of earth’s gravity, and all habitation
and activity modules will have this simulated
gravity. Voyager also understands that one
of the main reasons that people want to visit
space is to experience weightlessness. So,
they have arranged a solution for this as
well. Whenever you’re not sleeping or chilling
in one of their habitation modules, you can
take the elevator to the center of the space
station which will offer a zero gravity experience.
In terms of safety, Voyager plans to incorporate
44 emergency return vehicles into their space
station which is basically one for each habitation
module. These emergency return vehicles vaguely
resemble nasa’s space shuttle, and they
will be capable of completing an automated
flight back to earth. As for amenities, Voyager
is looking to match luxury hotels on earth
as much as possible. Their entry level hotel
suite offers 30 square meters or 320 square
feet of living space. These suites will support
up to 2 people and offer private bathrooms
which include both toilets and showers. If
you want something bigger, you can spring
for their luxury villas which are absolutely
massive. Each villa is expected to have 500
square meters or 5300 square feet of living
space. These villas feature cooking facilities,
three bathrooms, and can support up to 16
people each. Voyager is looking to provide
a gym and activity module as well. They claim
that these modules will be 7 meters tall and
support basketball, weight lifting equipment,
and cardio equipment. I don’t think anyone
visiting the space hotel is looking to get
a serious workout in, but it would be quite
interesting to try these tasks in an environment
with ⅙ the gravity of earth. Aside from
a gym, Voyager is also looking to offer a
restaurant and bar. Apparently, the restaurant
will feature iconic astronaut food like freeze
dried ice cream, but they’ll also serve
gourmet food that is delivered to the station
on a biweekly basis. The entire station is
expected to offer a total of 11,600 square
meters or 125,000 square feet of habitable
space. This is enough to support 280 guests
and 112 crew members. Considering the large
capacity of the station, John Blincow, the
leader of the effort, is hoping to bus customers
in using starships. That’s all great and
all, but when will it open and how much will
it cost? Well, their goal is to open in 2027,
so not that far from now. But the ticket price
is of course quite high given the scope of
the trip. Right now, a 3.5 day stay on the
voyager space station is expected to cost
$5 million per person. And that’s not including
the starship ticket there and back. Now, it
should be noted that visions like this in
the past have not exactly panned out. Orionspan
for instance pitched the idea of building
a small tourist space station in 2018. Their
vision was nowhere near as grand as voyagers,
but unfortunately, they were unable to raise
enough money and they would end up returning
all the money they raised and shutting down
the project. This isn’t to say that Voyager
will fail, but simply that the process of
building a space hotel is still extremely
difficult. Nonetheless, with Nasa opening
up the ISS for space tourism, multiple companies
working on space hotels, and rapid progress
with starship, I think it’s just a matter
of time until we see a full on space hotel
like Voyager envisions. Will we see it in
the 2020s, probably not, but will we see it
in the 2030s, quite possible. When do you
guys think we’ll see full on space hotels?
Comment that down below. Also, drop a like
if you guys would like to stay in a space
hotel one day when the tickets are cheaper.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.